bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociologue hausse aujourd'hui je
vous retrouve pour une nouvelle vidéo
dans laquelle nous allons parler
d'organisation
c'est quelque chose qui est revenu assez
souvent dans vos commentaires et sur
instagram seuil est de savoir comment
j'organise mes recherches et donc mes
études
le but de cette vidéo c'est de vous
montrer un petit peu des astuces mais
également des outils que j'utilise pour
travailler au cours de ma thèse alors
pour celles et ceux qui ne le savent pas
je suis doctorante en sociologie
pour autant ces conseils peuvent
s'appliquer à toutes les personnes qui
sont en étude que ce soit au niveau du
lycée de l'université qui font la
sociologie ou pas le but pour la 7 vous
donner des astuces pour pouvoir étudier
être motivés tous et notre discipline et
être plus efficace dans son travail donc
déjà ce que je fais c'est que tous les
soirs avant d'arrêter de travailler je
nettoie mon bureau quand le nettoyer
c'est à dire que je le range je referme
les livres je remet les choses à leur
place
pour arriver le matin et avoir un bureau
qui donne envie de s'installer qui
éclaire avec un espace de travail nets
est prêt à accueillir le nouvel journée
l'outil qui pour moi le plus important
c'est mon agenda
je suis un peu vieille école j'ai un
agenda papier sur lequel j'écris à la
main et c'est un agenda donc c'est un
type moleskine avec d'un côté la semaine
entière et de l'autre côté une page de
notes je vous ça super pratique parce
que ça permet d'avoir une vue d'ensemble
sur ma semaine et sur les grosses
échéances que je vais avoir et ça me
permet aussi de prendre des notes plus
détaillée quand j'ai des réunions des
choses comme ça donc la première chose
que je fais c'est le lundi matin de noté
mes objectifs de la semaine donc à la
fois les réunions importantes auxquelles
j'ai assisté les objectifs de lecture
d'écriture cgd deadline pour des
candidatures pour des appel à
communication d
demande de financement etc j'écris tout
dans une piscine tout doux avec des
boulettes en fait j'aime bien ce concept
parce que je me dis que ça laisse une
semaine entière pour accomplir de gros
objectifs
j'trouve que les totaux liste
quotidienne c'est bien pour se fixer des
objectifs plus petit mais au moins sur
la semaine ça permet de voir un peu les
les choses à faire et voilà je trouve ça
assez pratique la remet les idées en
place pour la semaine et ensuite on peut
organiser son comble ensuite au
quotidien vous êtes élu sur instagram
j'aime bien de temps en temps faire des
petites to do list quotidienne donc gelé
poste le matin et ça me motive en fait
de l'avoir montré à d'autres gens je dis
bah il faut que j'essaie de le faire
c'est vrai quand on voit doctorants d'un
première année je passe la plus grande
partie de mon temps à lire à prendre une
heure de lecture et a commencé à écrire
des réflexions notamment théorique
donc on a lié numéro un dans ce travail
de recensement biographique c'est otero
zotero c'est un logiciel de
bibliographie qui est très très très
pratique se dire que ça me sauve la vie
claire manquerait donc si vous
connaissent pas ou 0
c'est un outil qui peut paraître assez
impressionnant mais qu'au final est
assez facile à prendre en main en fait
le principe de zéro c'est que vous allez
lire un article lire un livre et vous
allez pouvoir enregistrer sa son
référencement donc que vous ayez
l'article en papier chez vous ou le
livre chez vous ou sur internet c'est
assez simple soit vous entré
manuellement les informations de livres
soit quand vous êtes sur internet vous
pouvez ajouter un petit plugin qui vous
permet de directement ajouté l'article
ou le livre en question à votre logiciel
donc par exemple c'était sur google
scholar qui est quand même loties numéro
un pour les personnes qui font des
études ou de la recherche c'est un
recensement de casement enfin la très
grande partie des articles scientifiques
qui sont produits donc vous êtes sur
google scholar vous entrer un mot clé
vous trouvez votre article et vous
cliquez sur le plugin salle ajoute à
votre bibliothèque zotero ça marche
aussi sur d'autres sites moi j'utilise
beaucoup kern pour les productions
francophones
ensuite une fois que vous allez être sur
d'autres c'est pour vous allez pouvoir
organiser votre bibliothèque en fête qui
est intéressant dans créant la
bibliothèque sur le terreau c'est que ça
nous oblige aussi à structurer le
biographie et du coup à définir les axes
et dans laquelle on a besoin de se
documenter
donc pour ma page est plein d'accès
différents des sous partie des soussous
partie bref ne prenez pas peur je
rappelle quand même que je suis en thèse
donc je lis plus que quand j'étais en
master ou en licence mais
avantage de ce terreau ne s'arrête pas
là déjà quand vous allez rédiger un
article
grâce à ce terreau où vous allez pouvoir
citer beaucoup plus facilement donc si
vous vous êtes dit j'ai quelque chose à
mémoire de voir et serra au lieu de
faire ajouter une référence mais c'est
une note de bas de page que vous rédigez
à la main et cetera vous allez pouvoir
en fait ajouter une note avec sottero
donc vous taper les premières lettres du
nom de l'auteur ou de l'autriche ou bien
de l'article et il va vous trouver
automatiquement et ajuster les
références en fonction des ja du style
de référence que vous devez utiliser
donc le style voilà anglophones
francophones sciences humaines ou pas et
en plus à la fin vous pouvez éditer
automatiquement la bibliographie dont
clairement ça change la vie parce que du
coup vos références à part quelques
petites modifications à faire elles
seront déjà nickel et l'autre astuce que
j'ai adopté complètement gm depuis mes
premiers mois de thèse c'est le fait de
pouvoir mettre des notes de lecture
directement dans le logiciel
en fait quand vous récupérez un article
ou un livre sur internet vela sottero
souvent il va essayer de vous trouver le
texte en format numérique donc déjà vous
avez ce pdf qui est associé tout de
suite à votre ouvrage quand c'est
possible et donc vous avez pas galérer à
le retrouver dans des dossiers etc
on peut aussi si vous avez un texte pdf
l'ajouter à une référence sur ce terreau
et surtout ce qui est super pratique
c'est que vous pouvez ajouter des notes
de lecture
donc moi je ne passe plus que par ça
parce qu'au début je m'éparpille et
j'avais des documents word dans tous les
sens je les perdais à moitié là vous
avez la possibilité d'écrire vos notes
de lecture directement dans le logiciel
et vous pouvez même ajouter des
marqueurs donc c'est comme des tags en
quelque sorte qui vous permet en fait de
par la suite retrouvé par exemple tous
les textes qui concernent
l'épistémologie qu'importe la catégorie
dans laquelle j'ai été classé au début
donc c'est super pratique et je pense
que c'est un outil qui va vraiment ma
compagne et jusqu'à la fin de ma thèse
parce que ça devient vraiment une
bibliothèque en ligne et la vente âge
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de risque de tout
perdre c'est vraiment ma grande angoisse
déjà je voulais préciser le terreau
c'est un logiciel gratuit libre
développé de manière indépendante et
surtout il sauvegarde en fait si vous le
souhaitez tout sur la plateforme en
ligne nous comme dans un drive en fait
tout un cloud du coup vous avez toutes
vos notes toutes vos bibliothèques et
sauvegarder en ligne
en même temps donc cet outil il a
apprécié eux ce que je pense que je vais
faire c'est aussi de temps en temps
imprimer mes notes de lecture quand
elles sont terminées pour me faire faire
comme un classeur de lecture parce que
je pense qu'au bout d'un moment au
niveau des yeux déjà moi ça me fatigue
l'ordinateur et puis en plus sa maman
d'avoir quand même une trace écrite sur
laquelle je peux faire des modifications
à la main et c'est donc voilà pour cette
grosse partie qui était otero je profite
de paraître de logiciels pour présenter
très rapidement calibre qui est un
logiciel qui me permet de gérer mes
livres numériques pour ma liseuse
donc j'ai une liseuse depuis de très
nombreuses années
c'est assez pratique notamment du fait
que j'habite à l'étranger donc je vais
en turquie j'ai pas eu la possibilité
d'amener tous mes livres avec moi et
j'ai pas non plus forcément la
possibilité d'acheter beaucoup de livres
en français donc c'est vrai que je
consulte beaucoup d'ouvragés en ligne
que ce soit des livres de littérature
plaisir ou des livres directement liée à
la thèse dont qu'ils soient au format
epub ou pdf je peux les mettre sur ma
liseuse grâce à calibre c'est un
logiciel qui permet en fait de stocker
des livres numériques de choisir
lesquels on ne bascule sur sa liseuse ou
pas là encore c'est un logiciel gratuit
développé de manière indépendante donc
je recommande ensuite l'autre partie
très importante de mon organisation et
bien ça passe par les mails donc j'ai
des boîtes mails qui sont donc les à mes
activités scientifiques grâce auquel je
me suis abonné à plusieurs listes de
diffusion dans le monde de la recherche
et de diffusion c'est vraiment un outil
essentiel
en fait je trouve que le plus gros
challenge quand on entraîne y rester et
notamment doctorat c'est d'avoir accès à
l'information aux événements en cours
aux appel à communication aux appel à
articles parce que ben en fait personne
va faire ce travail là pour vous donc
c'est à vous d'organiser votre système
pour faire remonter l'information et
parfois ça peut être un petit peu
difficile je trouve en tout cas quand
j'ai commencé moi j'ai vraiment eu du
mal à accéder à l'information
donc je me suis abonné à deux listes de
diffusion principal une case une liste
de diffusion disciplinaire qui
concernait sociologue et l'autre qui est
une liste de diffusion thématiques qui
concerne de manière générale les études
sur le genre
ça me permet de voir peu près tout ce
qui passe sur mes sujets d'intérêt
sachant qu' il faudrait que je me fasse
encore un peu des recherches pour
trouver d'autres listes de 10
fusion je pense également une autre
astuce c'est que créer fréquemment
presque tous les jours que je reçois des
mails de academia academia c'est un site
qui vous permet de trouver là encore des
articles ou des livres qui sont publier
des livres scientifiques et en fait ils
ont un système qui est très bien c'est
quand vous avez un texte qui vous
intéressent que vous télécharger au
format pdf
il vous propose de recevoir des
notifications pour tous les les textes
qui pourraient être relatifs à celui que
vous avez téléchargés j'ai décidé de
pouvoir recevoir ses mails et c'est vrai
que souvent ça me permet de découvrir
des autrices ou des auteurs auquel
j'aurais pas forcément pensé des textes
qui viennent de paresse ont des textes
qui sont pas forcément très connus et
auquel j'aurais pas accéder sans ça
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser dans la
même veine il y a un site qui s'appelle
connected paper que je vous recommande
vraiment qui est super intéressant
puisque vous pouvez rentrer le nom d'un
article scientifique et vous allez voir
par sujet en fait par thématiques tous
les articles universitaires qui peuvent
être connectés à cet article
enfin je vous parlais très rapidement de
sa robe quand même l'enjeu principal
quand on est en thèse en 2021
dans notre époque c'est d'accéder à de
la documentation en ligne
on est quand on n'est pas historien en
tout cas on n'a pas forcément la
possibilité de se déplacer dans des
bibliothèques qui possèdent nos livres
et a fortiori en étant à l'étranger
voyez il ya plein de livres auxquels j
pas accès au format papier et accéder à
certains articles en ligne ça peut être
très compliqué vraiment je pense qu'on
assistera jamais assez là dessus mais en
tant qu'étudiant que vous soyez un
master avant le masters ou que vous
feriez en thèse c'est inadmissible de se
dire que l'on doit payer des sommes
faramineuses pour accéder à du contenu
scientifique normalement vos universités
peuvent vous fournir des abonnements sur
la plupart des plateformes notamment
kern
mais voilà d'autres plateformes
également et sachez qu'en fait un auteur
ou une autre il n'est pas rémunéré pour
écrire un article universitaire et donc
les plateformes qui vendent l'accès à
ces articles c'est de l'argent qu'ils
gagnent pour leur fonctionnement interne
donc certes c'est important mais laissez
les gens qui veulent juste les consulter
et qui ont des moyens le faire et en
tant que master enfin qu'étudiant qu
étudiante au doctorat ans doctorante
s'il vous plaît ne payez pas 50 70 120
euros pour accéder à du contenu
numérique
en fait il ya d'autres manières alors je
sais que c'est pas forcément très légal
j'espère que que bon bref vous me
pardonnerez mais pour utiliser un
logiciel libre qui s'appelle sai robe
qui vous permet en fait à partir du
portail d'un site qui va vous bloquer
l'accès complet un article qui vous
permettent de le débloquer devient le
format pdf
voilà pour le gros point lecture
j'espère que vous n'avez plus à prendre
quelques astuces sur les logiciels ou
sur les sites que j'utilise en dehors
des lectures je passe une grande partie
de mon temps à répondre à des appels à
communication à faire des demandes des
financements à préparer des dossiers etc
ces deux tâches qui peuvent être
extrêmement chronophage et là encore
j'ai un allié de taille
tatelier c'est la méthode pour mot
d'euros donc pour vous taureau en
italien c'est à dire tomate est le nom
de cette méthode vient vous savez du
petit minuteur dans les cuisines en
forme de tomates tout simplement la
méthode pour me d'euros consiste en fait
à m 1
minuteur donc pour dans mon cas je
choisis de faire un minuteur de 45
minutes pendant ces 45 minutes vous
mettez votre téléphone en ne pas
déranger vous couper d'internet il n'en
avait pas besoin
bref aucune distraction vous ne
répondait pas au téléphone regardé par
vos notifications jusqu'à 25 minutes de
travail intensif en fait le fait de se
mettre un minuteur chauve que ça aide
vraiment à se forcer au moment où on
pourrait un peu faiblir en termes de
concentration pour ma part j'ai remarqué
qu'au bout de 20 25 minutes notamment de
lecture ou d'écriture de choses qui sont
pas super passionnante genre des lettres
de motivation ou ce genre de choses
eh bien j'ai tendance un peu a décroché
au niveau de la mer au niveau de la
concentration au niveau de l' envie de
travail et du coup le pommeau d'euros ça
m'aide à me dire bah écoute il faut
juste tenir jusqu'à la fin écrire
jusqu'à la fin donc je dépasse ce moment
où j'aurais lâché je pense en dehors du
pommeau d'euros et puisque je vous
conseille c'est de faire comme je fais
avec certains de mes amis doctorants et
doctorante c'est de faire des pommeaux
d'euros en ligne donc on est à plusieurs
on sens des pommeaux d'euros voilà c'est
peut-être même pas grand chose mais de
savoir que quelqu'un d'autre en train de
travailler avec nous ça donne une petite
motivation supplémentaire ensuite
l'autre conseil que je voulais donner et
je trouve quentin d'autodiscipline c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est assez
fondamentale en tout cas pour moi j'ai
quand on est doctorant doctorante on n'a
pas un chef qui va venir checker qu'on
n'est vraiment en train de travailler de
telle heure à telle heure on n'a pas
tout le temps des choses à rand a montré
il ya vraiment cette importance de
l'autodiscipline de se fixer des tâches
à faire donc je dirais que pour rester
concentré pour rester actif
le mieux c'est d'essayer de travailler
le plus qu'on peut moment on sent qu'on
est en train de décrocher
parfois il faut aussi se dire bah ok là
je décroche c'est pas grave je n'arrive
pas mais dans ces moments là moi mon
astuce c'est de ne pas aller me poser
dans le canapé l'on veut regarder une
série parce que sinon c'est fini
donc quand je sens que j'arrive plus à
tenir que mon cerveau n'est plus très
connectés ou que tout s'embrouille je
fais autre chose mais quelque chose de
productif
par exemple je fais la cuisine
je fais un peu de peinture enfin voila
je fais quelque chose qui est productif
mais qui me fait plaisir qui est en
dehors de ça je vais faire une balade de
enfin que sais-je
en tout cas quelque chose qui n'est pas
mature et réseaux sociaux ou me poser
dans le canapé parce que sinon c'est
fini
en fait le fait de rester actif dans ces
moments là ça me permet de revenir plus
facilement au travail derrière
et surtout j'ai remarqué depuis que je
fais ça en fait au début je vois là ça
me repose je suis vraiment concentré sur
la nouvelle chose que je fais et puis
d'un coup je reviens j'ai des idées qui
me viennent tous aligne un petit peu
dans mon travail tout je reviens madame
d'écriture je reprends ce que j'étais en
train de faire et c'est beaucoup plus
clair
je pense qu'en face le cerveau a tout
simplement besoin aussi de temps pour
décanter pour aligner des informations
et cetera est tout simplement c'est
possible quand vous êtes encore actifs
plutôt que quand vous posez vos cerveaux
à côté de vous et que vous regardez une
série en fait tout ça pour vous dire que
ce qui m'aide beaucoup dans ma thèse
c'est d'essayer de quantifier un peu à
peu près le temps que va me prendre une
tâche d'avoir conscience de combien de
temps je met à réaliser certaines choses
et choco plus on avance dans les études
et en plus on se connaît là dessus et
sur nos capacités de travail
c'est pas les mêmes pour tout le monde
ça dépend de plein de facteurs donc pas
de culpabilisation là dessus pour ma
part ce que je me dis c'est que si je
peux faire une tâche en moins de 30
minutes
eh bien je la fais tout de suite donc
tout ce qui est traité les mails
l'administratif
tout ça c'est pas agréable mais
franchement je me force à le faire tous
les jours pour ne pas être sous l'eau et
toutes ces petites tâches en fait qu'il
faut qu'ils prennent pas beaucoup de
temps mais qui en fait peut vite devenir
un fardeau je les fais tout de suite au
moment où j'y pense parce que ça me
prend moins de 30 minutes donc sa femme
handicapée dans ma journée
en terme de rythme de travail je sais
qu'on peut être très différents les uns
des autres moi ce que je me suis fixé
c'est de me dire que je me réveillais
avant 8h le matin sauf voilà
car xtreme mai
j'aime bien me lever vers 7h 7h30 en
tout cas à 8 heures je veux être debout
et je décroche de mon ordinateur au plus
tard à 19h30
j'essaie aussi de garder un rythme de
repas stable en fait j'essaie aussi de
garder le rythme qu'on aurait dans une
entreprise c'est avec une pause dej
véritable avec des heures de travail
matin après midi mais le grand avantage
en fait d'être en thèse l'aide de temps
et c'est vraiment une chance ces deux
pour être flexibles ont un emploi du
temps ne veut pas dire qu'on a rien à
faire un voeu contraire mais j'ai tout
simplement que l'on peut organiser notre
temps comme on le veut donc ça peut être
un grand bonheur quand ça peut être un
très grand problème
moi je veux vraiment pas me mettre avec
travaillé super tard le soir en dehors
de quand j'ai de grosses deadline parce
que je sais que c'est quelque chose qui
affecte vraiment mon rythme de sommeil
etc
donc j'essaie de me m'imposer un petit
peu cessera de boulot mais je reste très
flexible et si quelqu'un me propose
d'aller boire un café à 16h et bien je
m'organise en conséquence pour pouvoir
le faire autre chose qui est assez
important dans mon quotidien de
doctorante c'est le fait que j'essaye de
jongler entre l'ordinateur et les
formats papier donc j'ai plusieurs
carnets je vous le disais au début j'ai
un agenda qui est vraiment super
important pour moi mais j'ai aussi trois
autres carnets alors le premier carnet
c'est un peu mon carnet de test dans le
sens où cela que je vais prendre des
notes lors des réunions mais c'est aussi
là que je veux d'abord couché mais
première idée sur le papier quand une
communication je dois écrire un dossier
ex terra souvent les idées me viennent
plus facilement à l'écrit et même quand
je bloque un peu sur une rédaction je
reviens vers mon carnet j'écris un peu
ça me des blogs ça me permet de faire
mes flèches mais abréviation un peu
comme je veux et souvent ça m'aide à en
fait suivre plus rapidement ma pensée et
donc ensuite je peux revenir à mon
document word plus facilement mon
deuxième carnet c'est mon carnet
de terrain mon journal de terrain c'est
un document qui est essentielle en
sociologie mais également pour de très
nombreux chercheurs de disciplines
différentes
c'est tout ce qui va concerner l'enquète
de terrain pour ma part dans cadeaux
terrain c'est un peu compliqué en ce
moment si vous avez vu l'épisode de mon
journal de 16 à ce sujet vous savez
pourquoi pas les conditions sanitaires
actuels n'ont pas forcément l'aider mais
j'ai quand même pu prendre quelques
notes déjà le but de ce document c'est
tout simplement de pouvoir noter toutes
les impressions tout ce qui s'est passé
autour des entretiens qui sont
enregistrées c'est un document qui est
très important et qui est valorisé dans
la tête ou dans les mémoires de master
jai pas forcément métal et plus
largement sur ce qu'est le journal de
terrain mais on pourra en parler à
l'occasion dans une autre vidéo est un
sinon très incarné le carnet jaune et
c'est celui que je consacre à sociaux
lobos alors ce carnet une overdose
d'aimer cette vidéo l'agencement des
arguments que je veux mettre en avant
dans mes vidéos de prendre des notes sur
les ouvrages que je veux explicité dans
la vidéo etc
c'est un carnet d'enquêté très important
et d'ailleurs je voulais revenir un
petit peu sur la place qu associer le
russe dans ma tête
un point de vue très personnel socio
gosses ça me permet de sortir de mon
seul sujet de thèse pour explorer
d'autres thèmes qui n'ont rien à voir
avec mes recherches avec par exemple la
vidéo sur la prison sur les sondages sur
les mouvements de luttes sociales des
mères voilà il ya plein de choses
différentes que j'ai pu avoir des grâces
et asociaux logos et ça me permet en
fait de retrouver de l'enthousiasmé pour
mes recherches
un grand conseil que je peux vous donner
c'est de vous trouver une activité qui
vous aident à valoriser ce que vous
faites que vous soyez en étude
encore une fois lycée en ligne restait
en doctorat trouver une manière de
valoriser ce que vous savez ce que vous
faites je trouve que c'est important
parce que on n'a pas forcément
d'échéance à court terme qui nous
permettent de nous dire là je suis sur
le bon chemin là je suis en train de
réussir de faire de belles choses
du coup de poing faire des vidéos d'eux
voulait partager d'avoir vos retours ça
m'aide en fait à garder le moral a à me
dire que je progresse que j'avance et à
célébrer des échéances plus à plus court
terme que je préfère que ma thèse donc
ce que je dirais pour finir cette vidéo
c'est que s'organise et ça fait vraiment
un
très important pour être plus efficace
pour garder le moral et surtout pour
pouvoir continuer à se consacrer des
moments on n'est pas dans les études
être étudiant ou être géo jeunes
chercheurs être doctorants ça doit pas
devenir le centre de votre vie même si
bon j'avoue ça l'est mais vous devez
continuer à pouvoir faire autre chose
c'est pas normal de passer ses jours et
ses nuits tout entière sur nos études et
dans mon cas sur mon métier comme mon
futur métier
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que vraiment les bouts de cette vidéo
c'est de vous donner des outils pour
réussir à mieux optimiser votre temps
pour ensuite pouvoir profiter continuer
à voir vos amis à sortir à vivre vos
passions en tout cas à prendre du temps
pour vous c'est aussi super important la
productivité c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on a en claquant des doigts c'est
quelque chose qui s'entretient qui ce
travail est la première base de ce
travail c'est d'avoir une bonne santé
mentale d'être en forme d'avoir
confiance en soi et en ce qu'on fait et
pour ce faire il faut réussir à prendre
du recul et avoir du temps en dehors de
la thèse voilà pour cette vidéo j'espère
que ça vous a plu que ça vous a donné
plein de doughty et d'astuces pour
améliorer votre organisation cette vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre un gem
à vous abonner à la chaîne à me laisser
un commentaire à partager la vidéo
bref à faire vivre sociaux logos et je
vous dis à très vite sur social buzz
[Musique]